françois patriat donc le front national
sera dans de nombreux duels dans l'yonne
principalement contre des forces de
droite est ce que vous appelez la gauche
à voter pour les candidats de la droite
m pour ce qui me concerne je pense que
ce sera le fait la gauche a dit
républicaine il n'y a pas aucune
question à se poser nous appellerons à
voter pour le candidat de la droite
républicaine les choses soient claires
je reviens je reviens à l'instant en
arrière ces différents jeux dès que je
parle le mps salir les mains s'il vous
plaît très bien fini que nous
appellerons à voter pour donner plus que
moi je le dis le panini on vote pas pour
ni ni vote pour quelqu'un et le choix
pour nous éclaire jeu